now EU energy ministers are meeting in
Prague to find ways to tackle high gas
prices 15 members of the European Union
want the price of wholesale gas to be
capped across the block they do not want
richer countries in Europe to be able to
buy gas at higher prices
now the uh they argue that the cap would
help curb prices before expensive gas
supplies enter the market reach power
plants and therefore drive up
electricity bills The Proposal is based
on three ideas setting a limit on the
cost of Russian gas Imports negotiating
a lower gas price with other suppliers
and establishing a ceiling on the price
of gas used to generate electricity but
some EU member states disagree with the
plan and they want alternative options
including a limit on gas consumption and
subsidy packages for businesses and for
consumers
Sebastian is at that meeting in Prague
and joins me now so we just outlined
step that there are different views on
how to deal with this right how to
reduce gas prices in Europe
how deep are those divisions
well they are very deep but it's a new
day and a new meeting here in Prague and
also New Hope that they will come to an
agreement but last week's leaders Summit
here in Prague really failed to reach
that agreement and even worse it showed
the real deep divisions between the
different countries to 27 member states
especially between the so-called rich or
north and west maybe and the more poor
east and south they really have a
different view on how to resolve this
crisis the the more richer countries
really don't want any Market
intervention or at least try to limit it
as much as possible but at the same time
the handing out really large packages
for their own people to uh to to deal
with these high energy prices something
the the countries in the south and east
simply can't afford so this is where the
divisions are really at their deepest
and they have had meetings also last
night they've had meetings trying to
come to some kind of agreement I spoke
to the minister of industry and trade
here in the Czech Republic who is
organizing this meeting and he really
called on the countries to unite and to
show some solidarity because of course
amidst this whole war in Ukraine going
on what the EU wants least is to show
this Unity to show conflict they want to
show that they're strong against Russia
but this whole energy crisis is simply
showing something else and and your it
is true that the European Union
countries have been able to put up a
united front by and large when it comes
to the the Russia Ukraine crisis do you
think they'll end up agreeing on a price
cap
well that's a very good question uh the
the minister of industry and trade was
kind of optimistic they are discussing a
so-called compromise solution what he
really aims at now is to put a cap on a
gas for electricity so basically a lot
of countries are still using gas to
generate power and that really leads to
high bills for consumers so if they can
put a cap or they call it decoupling the
price from the gas price then that would
help a lot of consumers already it would
help a lot of countries but the same
system has been used since June in Spain
and Portugal and it has reduced prices
by nearly 25 percent but what it also
has done is it has increased consumption
and that's something that the EU
definitely wants to avoid because
they're really worried that they simply
will run out and there will be blackouts
and that is a real worry especially in
the countries like Germany that use a
lot of energy so it is is a discussion
that will be ongoing today and also the
Netherlands and Germany have put in
their own proposal still trying to avoid
this price Gap they're looking at a new
Benchmark price for LNG that's something
that's being discussed and they also
really push for a joint buying effort of
gas on the market for the whole block so
we don't expect any resolution today
what they're aiming for is now to reach
a compromise to reach a solution early
November but of course winter is already
kicking in here and people are really
worried with their bills now step listen
thank you very much for that explanation
because it can be hard to understand
exactly the mechanism how you get to
reduce the price of gas but the bottom
line is something very simple reducing
energy bills for consumers in Europe
Steph fasten thank you very much